hi I'm Matt Welch for recent TV and I'm
here today with Emily Ekins recent
polling director we're here to talk
about the results of our second
quarterly reason-rupe poll today we're
going to be talking a lot about spending
attitude sort spending entitlements and
the Tea Party Emily thanks for joining
us good to be with you we're talking a
lot in this poll about preferred modes
for deficit reductions you gave people a
variety of choices and what jumped out
at me is that the most popular solution
for reducing the deficit by far
thirty-seven percent of people said cut
spending only when it's more of like a
fifty-fifty cut spending raise taxes
that was twenty four percent and all the
way at the bottom the least preferred
solution was raised taxes only what's
going on there what can we read from
those numbers well there's a couple of
ways to think about it if you look at
those who want to primarily reduce
spending that has the most support 57%
want to primarily reduce spending of
which many of them do not want to even
touch taxes either however only
twenty-three percent want an equal
emphasis on raising taxes and lowering
spending and only fifteen percent want
to primarily raise taxes so this really
shows that the emphasis right now is on
lowering spending and it suggests that
when it comes to the budget crisis in
Washington the public thinks about it as
a spending problem not a revenue problem
there are other numbers in your data
that support that why do people think
that it's a spending problem or what are
other manifestations of that there are
several things to think about why first
about sixty nine percent of americans
think or anticipate their future taxes
increasing in the near future so that's
one and then two when we asked about
what they thought the government might
do with the money if they were to raise
taxes overwhelmingly people believed
that government would spend that money
on new programs rather than using that
money to address the federal deficit
another
reason why Americans are probably
looking to cut spending is that they
believe it will help the economy that on
net it will do more to help the economy
than hurt fifty-seven percent believe
that whereas only twenty percent believe
it we mostly harm let's go to
entitlements spending is the big
Megillah the elephant in the room of
spending sixty-seven percent say that
they're against raising the age for
Social Security 51% say they're against
cutting their Medicare benefits doesn't
the say that Americans are a bunch of
big fat hypocrites well there are
several things to think about when it
comes to Social Security and Medicare
reform when we ask the questions about
would you favor reducing social security
benefits and Medicare benefits we get
the typical response overwhelmingly
sixty percent people don't want to cut
these benefits also when we ask would
you favor means testing these kinds of
programs people they don't favor that
they oppose that they think that all who
contributed to the programs should
receive the benefits from them but we
need to take a step back and in our
survey we delve a little deeper into the
details and we try and understand how
people conceptualize and how they think
of these programs so when we asked
people if they would accept reductions
and Social Security benefits even to
balance the budget sixty percent say no
but then when we say or when we asked
would they accept productions that they
were guaranteed to receive all the money
that they and their employer contributed
towards the program the answer flips and
sixty percent say they would favor that
kind of reform and the same thing
happens with Medicare if people are
guaranteed to receive the money that
they and their employer contributed
towards it then it flips sixty percent
say they are in favor of reforming and
cutting these benefits also when we
asked if people would favor allowing
individuals to opt out of Social
Security and Medicare majorities approve
of this so if you basically get out what
you put in it would be fine it's it's
own it's somehow that people don't trust
that or that they they don't want their
money to go to people who didn't put in
as much money well there are several
aspects of
entitlement programs what this suggests
is that some Americans think of it like
a savings account they sacrifice by
contributing to it while they're working
and then they want that money to be
there so when polls ask people would
would you favor the government reducing
your Social Security benefits that
sounds like too many people would you
like the government to take your savings
and they say no I you know they think
that's their money and they contributed
to it so we specifically target that by
asking and it turns out that they would
favor reforms let's close up with a
discussion of the Tea Party the group of
people who are talking more about
cutting spending and even reforming
entitlements than probably any other in
American politics even though we saw a
lot of enthusiasm for cutting spending
we don't necessarily see a lot of
enthusiasm for the tea party I think 34%
only of Americans have set according to
your poll that the tea parties had a
positive impact on American policy or
politics and that kind of cuts across
different political groupings what's
going on with a with Americans attitudes
towards tea party yes it's a very hotly
debated issue in American politics right
now if you ask tea partiers eighty
percent say they've had a positive
impact on what in Washington but
interestingly some of the groups that
have the lowest support for the Tea
Party impact in Washington are actually
Republicans those who are Republican
that do not identify with the Tea Party
so this suggests that we're going to see
some some conflict as the the GOP tries
to find their presidential nominee for
2012 is it emerging some kind of
identifiable splits within the kind of
the broader right well we do know that
among tea party supporters they tend to
slightly prefer Rick Perry Michele
Bachmann and Ron Paul among non tea
party Republicans they they tend to like
Mitt Romney another thing that impacts
people's view towards the Tea Party is
what they themselves think that the Tea
Party is emphasizing go through that a
little bit yes so among tea partiers of
course themselves independents
Republicans
independent leanin Republicans they tend
to think that the Tea Party is primarily
about cutting spending and economic
issues however when we ask this of
liberals and Democrats they actually see
the Tea Party differently they think
it's more about social issues than just
economic issues and this probably
explains somewhat of their perception
about the Tea Party the Tea Party's
impact in Washington because they think
that the tea parties are are motivated
by things with which they disagree the
tea party man okay well that's great
thank you very much Emily for explicate
appalled 4recent TV I'm Matt Welch